hello I'm Conan O'Brien I purchased this
jacket online from a North Korean
magician and seeing it now on camera I
would read it up until this moment your
life has had little meaning but I'm here
to change all that because I'm here to
present the incredible team Coco I hope
you're ready for the future because the
future is sure ready for the you we'll
fix that
you'll get better the Team Coco tablet
app is a new way to watch Conan on two
screens one TV and one tablet Monday
through Thursday at 11 p.m. just fire up
the Team Coco tablet app while watching
Conan on TBS sit back and let the team
cocoa techno magic start delivering
exclusive content and conversation in
sync with the show you're watching by
the way anytime anyone says techno magic
I make money techno magic
techno magic technically you can
interact with friends and other fans
while behind the scenes photos trivia
and more appear right at your fingertips
you can also go back to previous items
it's as easy as scrolling through the
timeline this app has access to time
travel portals NASA doesn't want you to
know about this you'll see dinosaurs
remember you can use the team cocoa
tablet app with any recent episode of
Conan whether you're watching live on
your DVR or even on a full streaming
episode within the app itself
I smell innovation and onion mustard did
someone make a sandwich on this the team
cocoa tablet app also has all the
on-demand Coenen video clips slideshows
and blog updates you could ever want
there you have the team cocoa tablet app
it's better than you it's the team cocoa
tablet app one Conan now synced on two
screens all thanks to the power of 18 t
rethink possible go to team cocoa calm
to learn more
[Music]